[音楽]
[拍手]
競争地球学っていうちょっと変わった
タイトルで今日はお話ししますまああの
人身性っていう
言葉を聞いたことあると思いますまあ人類
の破壊の痕跡が
地層に残るとそれは大変だってことで些細
なビリティとか持続可能性とかね
完全にメインストリーム化してきてますが
いまいち持続可能性という言葉も現状維持
的なニュアンスがあって僕は好きになれ
ないもうちょっとですねこれちょっと
文字が重なっちゃってすいませんが
破壊でも
現状維持でもない
[音楽]
地球とのもうちょっとクリエイティブな
パートナーシップで地球の未来を作って
いく人類の未来を作っていくそういうこと
ができないものかというのが今日の主題
ですしかし
地球というパートナーというのは簡単です
がそんなに地球のことを我々は知ってんの
がもうちょっとちゃんと地球のことを
理解していこうということで
生きた地球を可視化しようという
コンセプトで
仲間たちと作ってきたのがこの地球儀です
で今これリアルタイムの
地球30分おきに
衛星からのデータがインターネット経由で
ダウンロードされてで昼と夜の境界線も
だいたい
現在ですねで例えば
イスタンブール
をやると
イスタンブールの現在の情景が出てきまし
た
ミラノ
どうだろう
結構ね
朝焼けっぽいミラノの風景
ジャカルタ
ミラノじゃないアルプスですけどね
視界の中川さんが
若干グッタ出身ということで
ジャカルタに
懐かしく帰っていただこうと思ってやって
みました
ヒエフ
ネットがちょっと遅れてて56分前となっ
てますが一応つい小1時間前のキエフここ
はまだ爆撃受けてないなと
毎日のようにここをこういうところを見
ながらですね人の姿がいまいちないのが気
になりますがということでいろいろこう
いうことができてもうちょっといろんな
地球の
体調をする
生きた地球を可視化するということで
いろんな研究機関とコラボレーションして
やっています例えばこれは東大の生産系の
吉村
計研究室とコラボして
梅雨時の雨今頃の
雲
可視化してますに
乗って大量の水蒸気が流れてくる
しかしさあそれは
どんなもんなんだろう日本の雨はインド
から
これはですね吉村
先生の
研究水の同意対比を分析するとその水蒸気
の起源がわかるでこれはまだ4月ですけど
早く
やると今日はちょっと時間がないので急ぎ
ますが
インド洋紀元のですね水蒸気がだんだん5
月の末から6月になると日本まで来るこう
いうふうに日本の梅雨時の雨の10粒に
一粒は
インドから来てるということが
科学的なエビデンスでちゃんと
可視化されるわけですよねそれから
例えば
他に
これはですね
面白いデータなんですけど
砂塵サハラの砂これは日本の黄砂もそう
ですけど
意外と
ミネラル鉄分とか豊かでですねこういう
ものが
編成あの貿易風に乗って大西洋にこう
降り注ぐそのおかげでここはすごく豊かな
漁場になって日本人が食べるタコの8割は
だいたいこの辺のモロッコとか
モーリタニアで
漁獲されたものになってるしそれが貿易風
に乗ってさらに
南米まで届いてアマゾンの森を育ててると
いうような研究がある
地球のつながりっていうのがこういう風に
可視化されてきた時代なんですねそれから
台風これねサハラの砂がAmazonを
育てる
台風は海をよみがえらせる
出してのは価格データです全部
早くでもこの台風もですね
災害とばっかり僕らは思ってますが例えば
沖縄の
美ら海水族館の館長さんなんかと話すと
今年は台風が来ないんで海が痩せてます
サンゴが発火しちゃってどういうことです
かこれを見るとわかります
これ台風がですね
海水温の高い海域をずっと言ってどんどん
発達するしかし
台風が過ぎた後に
海が多く変わってますよねつまり台風が
すごいミキサーですから
海を深いところまでかき混ぜて
深いところにある冷たくてミネラル豊かな
深層水を壁やからせるそれによって
プランクトンが増えて魚も増えてサンゴも
葉っぱが
収まるというようなことですねこういう
ふうに見ていると
本当に
我々謙虚になります
科学っていうのはさっき原田さんのお話も
当たり前にわかったつもりの世界をもっと
もっと解像度高く
再発見する
新鮮な形で
本当に地球もですね僕ら
知ったつもりになってたけどこういうふう
に見ていくとものすごく
地球ってすごいなっていう本当に謙虚に
なるところがあります
早くこれもですね
これ二酸化炭素今は本当にあの
悪者扱いされてますがで実際人類はもう
本当に
毎日1億トンぐらいの
CO2を排出していますけれどもこれ
特にヨーロッパあたりから
排出された
工業地帯が廃止されたものが
偏西風に乗ってシベリア
相当濃度が高くなってますよねところが
これもう少し見ているとですねだんだん
青く変わってきますなんでここに
グラフが出てますがCO2のグラフって
ギザギザしながら上がる
みんな習いますよね
なんでギザギザッて毎年夏になると下がる
かこれ
シベリアの森が
主要巣を吸収してるんですねもちろん熱帯
林ももっと吸収しますが寝たりは1年中
同じような気候これはもう
6月とか7月とかですね夏になると
ものすごく
光合成活動が盛んになってこれだけ資料
供給して
これだけ地球の
体調管理に
貢献してるわけですね
CO2を森は吸収するか大切にしよう
習っても言います一つ実感がわからない
こういう形で私たちは生きた地球を
可視化することができる時代になってきて
ますところがその森が
森林火災
森が焼けるって言うと色々あの最近も
コアラが焼け出されるオーストラリアとか
いろんなニュースを見ますけども
シベリアの話はあんまり聞かないかもしれ
ないでも
実はこれ衛星が捉えた
シベリアの
毎年10万平方キロメートルと日本の面積
の3分の1近い
面積がどんどん
毎年
焼けて亡くなっているその原因はもちろん
地球温暖化ですよね
地球温暖化
もっと早く
これは青かった地球がどんどん赤くなって
で赤を通り越してもっと高温になった
ところ黄色く白熱するというような表示に
なってますが
特に
北極とかですね
ヒマラヤとか氷に覆われたところが
高音化が
早く進む
わかりますよね
白いTシャツ着てると
光を反射する9割反射し9割しか吸収し
ないところが
白い氷が溶けて黒い地肌とか海面が出て
くると
9割九州して1割しか反射します
急速に
正のフィードバックと言いますか
特に北極とかヒマラヤで
北極のみならずユーラシア大陸全体がもう
黄色く発熱してるっていうこれをよく
考えてください
実際にですね
この森がこうやって失われて北極が
急所のように地球全体を
動かす例えば2010年のニュース検索
すると
ロシアで5万人熱波で亡くなった同時に
熱波干ばつで小麦の収量が減りましたその
結果その輸入小麦に頼ってたずっともう
シリアとかですね中東は間伐で
悩んでて農業ができないコーチの半分家畜
の8割がもう
放棄してせざるを得なくてそういう人たち
がみんな都市に流入して
輸入穀物をお金で買うそういう生活をして
いたそこに
プーチンからの金融小麦が入ってこなく
なったそこでも食料機器ですよねだから今
ウクライナの
トリガーになった食料機器が言われてます
がこれでデジャブですもう10年前にです
ねすでにそういうことがあってそういう
構造的な
脆弱性を人類は
社会が抱えているということがわかって
ましたあるいはヒマラヤさっきヒマラ大変
幸運化してましたよね中村哲さんが
井戸掘り
水道
掘削
せざるを得なかったこれはもう本当にあの
ヒマラヤというのはアジアのみず銀行です
甲賀とか揚子校とか全部集まってますで
そういう形で
人類は大変な脆弱性を抱えているわけです
もう中国インドを合わせて40億人がその
水で農業をしているそれができなくなっ
たら誰が壊していくのかしかし
希望はないのかっていうと
十分ありますこれは
ノーベル賞の学べ博士の
シミュレーターという想像力の飛び道具と
僕が呼んでますがもっと
早くさっきさっきのシナリオはですね
bauシナリオビジネス
要するに今まで通り稼ぎ燃料に依存して
高度成長を追求してたら地球はどうなるか
でも
ユーラシア全体が
黄色でしたよねところが
もっと早く
まあ2050年ぐらいまでは同じように
思われますがでちょっと黄色くなりかけて
ますが21世紀
後半2100年の状態さっきの
ユーラシア全体が黄色を確立する状態に
比べて
相当違う
シミュレーションですからこの通り行くと
は限らないけど
我々結構
未来を変えられるで人類の力人間なんて
地球に比べて小さいもんだと思ってません
それ大きな間違いですこの半世紀で常識が
変わりました何しろ前の東京オリンピック
から今まで
50億人増えましたこの50数年で50億
人増えた大人も子供もほとんど知らないで
それがザブザブと石油を使う生活を
以前はG7の7億人が今も数十億人がそう
いう生活をするようになったでその結果
CO2の累積使用2の
半分はこの30年ぐらいで出してところが
それだけ地球を数十年で変える力は
逆に使えばもっとポジティブに
変える
可能性が大きいわけですよねそれから人類
や進歩しすぎて地球を壊してんじゃなくて
まだまだ
未熟だ99%もだっていうのは
例えば
NTTがやってる高電融合とかですねもう
すでに
電力消費が100分の1に2030年まで
にするメドが
立ってきたとかですね
水の消費なんかも東大発のベンチャーの
ウォーターとかですねもう本当に100分
の1の水でシャワーやトイレを使えると
いう生活
決して技術至上主義で言ってるわけでは
ないけれどもこんな
平和の武器を私たちが手にしつつある時に
地球の未来をもっとクリエイティブに作っ
ていくことができるはずだでグッド
ニュースは2030年時点の都市の
あれはこれから作る
都市域はこれから作るこれはですね
もっと早くどんどん大都市が
成長する今でも大変なのにこれからもっと
販売になる大変だしかしこれは希望です
もう半分がこれから作るんだったら今の
ような100分の1の醤油電力や
水で
作っていけば
相当させるな
未来ができるで地球と人類の未来を変える
可能性が出てくるということですねという
ことで私は人類性を人身性という概念を
人類社会のOS更新を通じて地球のOSを
更新する正規というふうに
最低限したいと思ってますで
地球はですね
生命が作ってきました人類は
地球のOSアップデートする唯一の生物で
は決してありません
シェアのバクテリアが酸素のなかった地球
を酸素に満ちた地球に変えその結果酸素の
一部が大損を形成しUVカットソーができ
たおかげで
緑の植物から陸上に抽出したけどもその緑
っていうと地球にいいことだっていう
みんな思ってますけど
できた当時のあれ陸人やセルロースという
分解できないものでも大量にそれが
積もり積もって石炭になりましたがまあ
言ってみれば3億年前2億年前のプラごみ
みたいなものですでもそれもまた分解して
循環できる
白色給付金とかですねそういうような
声明が発達して今の
ゴミも全く存在しない
ゴミをうんちも存在しないそんな地球OS
を
生命がコラボレーションして作ってきただ
から
僕は
生命と地球のこの共進化の歴史の延長に
人類と地球の共進化の物語をだから今の
対応を発電とか
宇宙対応を発電人口光合成これもですね僕
は市販のバクテリア陸上職員に続く
光合成革命3.0と呼びたいそれはただ
単に
対応エネルギーを反映するだけじゃなくて
宇宙見ますとすごいことが起こってるじゃ
ないですかこの星では
酸素水素炭素
窒素というもう宇宙にありふれたビッグ
バンで宇宙にばらまかれた
ビッグバンディアに中央新星爆発で
ばらまかれた
当たり前のレゴブロックが散らかってる
部屋がそこら中にあるしかしある部屋で
だけはその連合ブロックが誰が組み立てる
のかわかんないけどすごい造形物になって
いる
キューってそういう方針なんですよねで
それをさらにアップデートアップグレード
していこうというのは人類の今のこれまで
も水田とかですね
伝統的に焼け旗とか地球の
OSアップグレードしてくる
歴史もありましたそれから今日はもう時間
がないんで終わりますが
地球の旬あの
津波なんかもね
東日本大震災の津波
津波があって
今度は
逆からも
チリからも津波がわーっときますがまあ
ちょっとあえて
挑発的に言います寄せては返す波こういう
ふうについ50年前30年前までは日本は
地震国だだけどプレートテトニクス理論が
確立されたのは1980年代ですでこう
いうふうに30年ごと60年ごと150年
ごとにこういう津波っていうのは寄せては
返す波のようにあるこれは必然なんだと
いうことは人類史上を初めて
激甚災害を
良き
予測予防減災する自由を獲得した
世代のすわれわれその自由を
生かさずに20世紀型と同じ防災をやって
いるだけでは
不十分じゃないでしょうかそれから
魚もですねイワシが取れる時期サンマが
採れる時期
結構
数十年ごとに交代するそれは気候の
オシレーションねあの往復運動でという
ことはわかってきたそうすると
イワシが取れない時には高値になって
みんなそれを買うそうじゃなくて言われ
ない時には様を食べましょうみたいに
地球の旬に合わせた
地球のリズムに同期した消費ができるよう
になるともっともっとクリエイティブに
地球と
共生競争できるんじゃないかそれが私が
申し上げたいことでしたということで
我々のOSを更新して
生命と地球の共進化の歴史を続けていく
短時間でお話しできないけれども
続きはあのエグゼビションの方にも行き
ますんで
ぜひ来てくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]